okay so as a lot you guys know there's
been a lot of exciting news coming out
of comic-con this week including
announcements about a Jurassic Park for
spider-man all different types of
superhero things you know a whole bunch
of things that comic book fans are just
salivating over I've been talking a lot
about spider-man on my channel lately
and I've gotten a lot of hate for word
and mostly because I expressed that I'm
not a fan of the suit and I don't like
the tone of the new film and I'm worried
about Andrew Garfield and I love Tobey
Maguire and all that kind of stuff so
listen so I'm going to talk to you guys
a little bit about something that
happened at Comic Con recently that I
really thought was really cool check out
this video I think this might be the
most incredible day of my life be at
Comic Con in college as spider-man with
all of you guys is always
a fan and this is my first time so here
I am as a fan
things I manager God feel that I'm going
to be here introducing this panel this
amazing spider-man panel suddenly says
that the reason why Spidey is so popular
is because all of us can relate to him
and I agree I needed Spidey in my life
when I was a kid and he gave me hope in
every comic I read he was living out
mine and every skinny boys fantasy -
what that was really neat how Garfield
was able to express his love for
spider-man and that made me have a lot
more confidence in him because I'm
always really weary whenever a character
that I love and have loved since I was
young is taken over by an actor and I
just I'm always afraid that he's not
going to do it justice the first time I
kind of heard about a reboot as you know
it was very excited in fact my reaction
is pretty much this I grew up watching
Dragonball Z and I've always loved
Dragonball Z as a kid and when I found
out they're making a live-action version
of the film
I was very skeptical I don't have an
all-time favorite movie people always
ask me what's your all-time favorite
movie I can't decide I do ever have a
least favorite movie and that is
Dragonball Evolution I hate that movie
it just ruined my childhood I got this
interview about Justin should how when
talking about Goku because a lot of kids
love love Dragonball and I think that
it's uh give me a fun adventure film do
you think that the role a has some have
a special message for the people yeah
definitely I think that the thing that
the character of Goku is a important
character to play because it's been
around on kids cartoons for a while so I
hope I can do the job right he has no
idea what to say he had no idea what he
was doing playing that character and as
we know that did not turn out very well
so I've always been really afraid
whenever a new person takes over a
character i lo however Andrew Garfield
clearly has a huge love for the
character of spider-man and after seeing
that video and seeing him express how
spider-man you know made him feel good
as a kid and helped him when he was
going through problems and how much he
loved being there for the fans and
everything that made me realize that he
has a lot of respect for that character
now I have full confidence in him as
spider-man seeing that video kind of
reminded me of this thing where a
classmate wrote to Johnny Depp asking
him to help her perform a mutiny on the
teachers at her school and he actually
came to the school and dressed up as
Jack Sparrow and telling all the
classmates hell it's not a good idea
I love when actors are so appreciative
of their character and of their fans
they will do something like that
for the fans and express their love for
that character and that's when I know
that an actor is appreciating what he's
doing and will do and will give respect
to a character so yeah there's a lot of
interesting things happening at Comic
Con this weekend I'm going to try to
bring out some of the really cool
tidbits like Jurassic Park 4 was
officially announced for the one
millionth time I think I've been talking
about that for like 10 years but I guess
they showed some footage of the lizard
and it wasn't so much like actual
lizards but more like a humanoid with
scales kind of thing let me know what
you guys think of Andrew Garfield
playing spider-man I'm pretty sure most
of you appreciate it however please
let's stop with the dissing of total
McGuire because to be honest I feel like
he did a very good job as Peter Parker
and that as an actor he's very
underrated in general so let's stop that
because he brought the character of
spider-man to a lot of kids who didn't
know about spider-man and got into
spider-man because of those movies so I
think some respect is deserved but
tomorrow I'm going to see Crazy Stupid
Love it is screening and Tuesday I'm
seeing Cowboys and Aliens look forward
to that